so everything for me whether I'm that
little uncoordinated kid it's taken a
lot you know it's taken me 30 years to
find any kind of success or any sense of
okay I'm starting to find
myself you know probably 2 or 3,000
speaking engagements before I felt like
I was comfortable on stage three
businesses that were freaking jamming
before I said you know you might be a
you might actually be a legitimate
businessman you know now now we're at
seven businesses we'll do probably 150
million bucks this year I got I'll hit a
billion dollars in real estate probably
before the year's over I'm just starting
to feel like you know what
maybe maybe I'm going to make it